is
the the the deep anchoring and the
cognitive dissonance around subjects and
the inability to decide to be able to
say maybe it is too
uh is there is there so much more
anchoring and anger
as a result of actually
trauma being activated or is it
more fear
i'm curious that i just that sprung to
mind and i was like man is this actually
like trauma activation happening with
people sure absolutely
so many i mean if you you look into
the backgrounds or the life histories
when people are are very
um
negative disruptive right like you know
negative or harmful forces in the world
around us whether that's in big ways or
it's just in the hey i don't care who's
right i want to have my way right
you know when you look underneath of
that that very often there is trauma not
always right but but i've learned over
20 years of doing what i do
that if you look for trauma you very
often find the answer right why is that
person not stopped drinking after five
residential rehab stays right why is
this person still depressed after so
much depression treatment right why why
can't this person sleep right and we
have such a reflex it says we'll give
them more antidepressants give them more
sleeping medicine but we don't look at
why
right and so
often i mean so often if you engage in a
process of exploration of dialogue what
you find is that yes
trauma is underlying those problems but
what but trauma makes a reflex of shame
in us we feel guilt and shame and
anxiety and fear and then it changes our
ability to see
right what has happened to us so so you
think there's very there's very
if it's hard to imagine a worse enemy
right than an enemy that changes how you
think right and makes you feel a sense
of guilt and a sense of shame and a
sense of being beleaguered which often
makes a sense of defensiveness which can
lead to a sense of digression sometimes
right and that you don't even know the
difference
right and that's often what trauma does
to us you know i told this story of a
young woman who before of an acute
terrible trauma you know saw herself as
somebody who could navigate the world
right and she was a bright and engaging
and people liked her and you know people
she was interested in dating wanted to
date her and she had education
opportunities and that she thought well
of herself and then she won an award at
some point you know i think back even in
high school for like being smart and
great about something you know and and
it was like how she thought of her so
she kind of anchored herself to like hey
that thing was great right and it shows
like i can go do what i try to do even
though you know there were she had a lot
i get going against her she was trying
to navigate the world right then after
the trauma
her whole story changes and she doesn't
know it
right it changes it no one likes me no
one will ever love me i'll never have a
good relationship i can't make my way
into work oh and that award it was a
life laughing at me right here's the
best you're ever going to do with
yourself even though you're in high
school this award that someone gave to
me even i didn't deserve it right i mean
it all changed in her and by the way
i've seen this over and over and over
it's just it's just one very clear
example without her having any
understanding and say wait did is that
how you felt about yourself before
this is truth what do you mean it's of
course that's how i feel about myself
look you know i've known you for years
you never felt like this before right
then we can start to begin exploring
that and that happens in us with traumas
often that extend back to childhood but
but you're not always they don't always
have to go back to childhood but they
often do
and they change the way that we're
functioning the way that we're taking
care of ourselves the way that we're
interacting with other people and often
we don't know it which is why you know i
have an entire clinic where we we take
care of people from the clinical and
consulting perspectives and trying to
help them understand themselves and so
often how do we help people get better
is we look at the their history and what
they're saying to themselves and what
their life narratives are and what the
role of trauma might be
and it just makes sense you know where
we're moving towards vending machine
medicine like just give me an inventory
of your symptoms right and without
making eye contact i'll flick a medicine
back to you i mean how could that work
right
does that make sense out of i was saying
a lot about it but it's a hundred
percent i
it's just it's the roots of it like you
can keep like putting a band-aid on a
bullet hole but like it's got to fix the
problem at some point in time and
what is your opinion on
because i i mean maybe i should go back
my experience is everyone has trauma on
some level it might not be manifesting
in a really big way in your life it
might be like and it can be really you
know comes from simple places
um but there is definitely like an
aspect of the self-help community that
uh would say i don't think this isn't
like a a psychologist's uh
perspective i don't think cause this not
the point of the actual job but that
there's a bypassing that you can just
out-think it you can just choose what
feels good and that is i feel like
there's a rise in that but there's also
a rise in practices that you have and i
remember having a conversation with my
mom and just talking about something and
some issue that she had had and i was
like hey you know did you and dad ever
think about going to therapy and she
went no
right like it was
you only went if you were a psychopath
right or if you had
like some kind of really terrible
manifested depression that made you
debilitated to some level right but i
feel like there's also a rise to
going to therapy i go to therapy i
sometimes have two therapists at once
like
i love the work
um so i'm just curious what's your
opinion because both of them are on the
rise but i think there's some bypassing
happening if you act like you can solve
your problems by just make pretending
like they're not there
but absolutely i mean i i would say this
i still say this a lot but i would say
this when i was teaching all the time
that lucas there's like three kinds of
people right the people who have real
mental health problems right bad
depression um bad ptsd with panic
attacks right or any kind of post trauma
syndrome ptsd is just one of them right
so they're people of real mental health
problems right they're people who aren't
alive right and the rest of us all have
mental health issues
right i mean it's complicated to
navigate the world right it's
complicated to go forward with all the
things that happen to us right and if
someone comes in our door and they don't
have a post-trauma syndrome they haven't
made changes in their brain but they've
had issues of like this stressor or that
stressor this trauma or that trauma
right but not big enough to change the
brain well guess what that's worth
talking about too yeah right i mean i go
to psychotherapy
weekly as well and have for years and
years and like sometimes i have
something problematic to talk about but
if not i mean my goodness there there's
enough in my life
that it could help me function better so
this idea that like we can all benefit
from grounding to ourselves and what's
going on inside of us what are the
stressors and what are the decisions
that we're making absolutely and then we
can shift back and forth between having
a problem and having issues right so as
i wrote about in the book that i wrote
after my brother's suicide i had
real problems i mean my brother chose to
end his life by suicide and it deeply
impacted myself and my parents and when
i looked back i had no mental health
background i was lucky that i had people
around me who were helpful and
supportive right and and helped me get
through it but you know my thoughts
about myself and whether the world was
safe enough and i could go make
something of myself in it had really
shifted right i knew something was
different i knew something was wrong i
wasn't taking care of myself like i did
before and i was unhappy and i was
depressed i was not just unhappy i went
for that to depress and i was drinking
too much and you know and
you know i really didn't have a
knowledge of like oh you think about
yourself differently or you have an
internal dialogue that's built around
shame now and built around shock and did
you know i needed help then and there's
no
shame to that right in a sense right
like trauma makes us want to feel
ashamed so that we hide it's it that's
like you know that's
the ultimate in evil right that the
thing that you need help with creates
shame that makes you hide it
right but we we absolutely need help if
it rises to the point we're not sleeping
well we're depressed we can't get it out
of our minds then we need to go and get
some
help and when we do
it can change things just like you know
if one hurts one's knee or you know one
has a problem in their lungs like we go
see yeah people to help us and it's no
different i mean if you imagine
how if it's okay i'll give an example
how after certain if trauma rises to the
level of overwhelming or coping skills
right then our brain function changes
like we were talking about earlier right
and we can't just think our way into
changing that back right is this anxiety
well it gets to be it's more than just
anxiety can manifest itself as anxiety
but they're automatic things that go on
in the brain so for example the idea of
like how do we react if we if we're not
on the other side of trauma that's
overwhelmed or coping mechanisms when we
see a new person right is we we look at
that person and we look for for interest
like do you look interested in me do you
look benign right do you look like you
might have something to offer in a
conversation right we look for other at
other people with a sense of of
curiosity right and interest in them
after trauma in the way that get
overwhelms our copings because we're
different going forward then we're
looking at other people through the lens
of vigilance mechanisms which is really
like are you do you mean me harm
right the thing about that's not the
best way to go through
life if we're trying to like do the best
we can at our job right or people are
trying to find someone to have a
relationship with or you know whatever
it may be even like meeting a new
neighbor if you know if we automatically
say i see you i don't know you and i
automatically thinking are you trying to
harm me right
that is so different than the kind of
openness
right that we feel
if we're not in that situation and the
idea that we're just going to think our
way out of it right it's just like it's
not how that works no more than if
someone has an acl tear and you think
i'm just going to look at it like this
until it fixes itself right
right so so if we recognize what's going
on inside of us and we look at what's
our internal dialogue what are we saying
to ourselves right as the day
goes along right what's our life
narrative what do i think of my life
what kind of story would i tell right
these are the ways that we start to get
in touch with what's going on inside of
us so that we can again be empowered
right like you said sovereignty or what
sometimes is called agency of like look
i've got i'm in charge of myself right
i'm an adult and i'm in charge of myself
in a world that doesn't make that easy
right so i want to be at my best which
means i want to understand myself as
best i can what do i have going for me
right i don't want to see myself through
the lens of guilt and shame and fear and
anxiety right that comes on the other
end of
of trauma if that makes sense
[Music]